I remember being at my mom's and I was
pacing around on her deck and I said mom
I can't live like sending Walt and the
look on my mom's face was devastating
[Music]
we're heading to the home of Amy melon
she lives just outside of Portland
Oregon Amy's got a pretty crazy story
she was in a bad car accident in 2006
and ended up on several different
painkillers she tried to get off of them
but kicking prescription opioids is
really hard she ended up going through
detox 27 times this is Amy's story hi
good to meet you my head hit the
concrete and my arm hit the concrete
that was the accident that started the
whole thing it was just a very short
split-second in my life so I wake up in
the hospital bed my arms with a splint
I'm hook up to IVs for me - all of a
sudden have these really strong
medications in me was something I had
never had any experience with in fact I
didn't grow up around drugs at all one
of the main things I was on was pain
medication that was the biggest one the
opiates nerve medication that was daily
I also was on anti-anxiety medication
this one I took for withdrawals I would
need another pharmaceutical to help me
off of that pharmaceutical doesn't make
much sense
doctors usually prescribed pain
medication in limited amounts over short
periods of time at the height of Amy's
addiction she was taking more than 20
pills a day so once I asked you guys
what life at home was like and what your
mom was like after the accident in 2006
we were so young when it happened that
it's basically the person on the meds is
who we knew she was quiet and you know
just she never left her bedroom she was
dull I mean she didn't really she wasn't
like she was lifeless I was like she was
alive but she wasn't alive it was really
hard to just see her just lay in pain
and cry in bed because there was nothing
that would actually help it the u.s. is
one of the only countries that
prescribes opioids for chronic pain
Americans now consume more than 80
percent of the world
pain killers after decades of this kind
of behavior the country is now facing a
public health crisis 78 people die each
day from opioid overdoses when did I
decide I didn't want to do pills anymore
I had another accident in October 2014
my notification made me blackout at the
wheel when Amy came to she realized she
was swerving off the road and the whole
time I was holding on to the steering
wheel spinning around and I am thinking
there's absolutely no way I can live
through another accident like this
talking to Amy's family and seeing
photos from her accident really brought
to light the amount of trauma they must
have gone through I met a completely
different person from the one described
clearly whatever she did to get off the
pills worked very well in part two Amy
shows us the treatment that changed her
life
Oh